hello good evening the united states has
called a drone strike it launched in
afghanistan at the end of last month a
tragic mistake officials have confirmed
10 civilians including at least seven
children died in kabul no islamic state
militants were killed general frank
mckenzie the head of u.s central command
says his condolences are with the family
and friends of those who lost their
lives
having thoroughly reviewed the findings
of the investigation and the supporting
analysis by interagency partners i am
now convinced that as many as 10
civilians including up to seven children
were tragically killed in that strike
moreover we now assess that it is
unlikely that the vehicle and those who
died were associated with isis k or were
a direct threat to u.s forces
i offer my profound condolences to the
family and friends of those who were
killed well to washington our u.s
correspondent martha keller and martha
there were reports of this at the time
people on the ground said that it was
family members that were killed and the
u.s denied this and said it was
militants until now
yeah general mckenzie they're saying he
offers his profound condolences to the
families of those who were killed in
that drone strike it's important to note
that as recently as monday the pentagon
was saying that this was a strike based
on good intelligence and they said it
was necessary to provo prevent further
attract attacks on american troops
outside the airport in kabul now this
strike was initiated at a time of
incredibly high tension in kabul just
days after the suicide bombing attack
which killed 13 u.s military members and
scores of afghan civilians on the ground
general mark milley the the chairman of
the joint chief of staffs said in the
wake um of that strike that officials
had very good intelligence and that it
was necessary to prevent further attacks
like that one that we saw outside the
airport
over the period of the last couple of
weeks it's become accepted that
civilians were killed in that attack and
but the u.s defense was still saying um
that isis at least one isis member an
isis facilitator had been killed in that
drone strike on august the 29th they now
accept that no isis facilitator was
killed in that drone strike and in fact
it's accepted now that it was ten
members all of the same family seven
were children and one was a toddler
three adults three men that were killed
were also on the u.s visa pathway now
accepted that this has been a failure of
intelligence um it's thought that the
explosives that they believed that were
inside um a toyota van a toyota sedan
van that the family were traveling in
were in fact water bottles that's just
one of what um it's assumed has been a
series of intelligence failings now
president biden was briefed on this um
on the findings of this report this
morning in the white house he's now
departed the white house to one of his
homes in delaware but we're expecting
that over the next few days we may hear
from the president serious questions not
just about this failing of intelligence
but about what this means for the use of
drones um as a way of attacking um
outside
targets in the future president biden
said in the wake of this attack that it
had been a success and it had been
showing the success of what he called
over the horizon
attacks in afghanistan a way of
launching these strikes from outside the
country but clearly this
places more questions over whether drone
strikes will be used by the us in the
future this just the latest in a line of
failures of using this type of
intelligence and this type of strike
martha thanks very much